just because you're not paranoid doesn't
mean they're not really after you so I
want to talk about something that just
keeps intermittently cropping up in my
comments section usually in regards to
DC EU movies though it also came up in
regards to Star Wars the last Jedi and
it's this ongoing belief of some people
that critics are bribed and that ratings
through things like Rotten Tomatoes or
whatnot are rigged and there is a big
conspiracy to ensure that certain
Studios get positive critical reviews
while other ones get negative and I want
to talk about that in specifics because
it's ridiculous and I want Eakes I want
to explain why and not just sort of wave
my finger right but I also want to talk
about it here so I don't ever have to
talk about it again
ideally so let's look at the the
assertions so the general assertion
seems to be that when some movies that
some people either believe are good get
very negative reviews or some movies
that certain people believe are not good
give very positive reviews that that
can't simply be a difference of opinion
that there is a pattern and where
there's a pattern there must be some
mechanism there's something manipulating
there was a reason why this happened now
personally I tend to subscribe to our
comms razor all things being equal the
simplest explanation is usually correct
and the simplest explanation is the
opinion you had about a piece of media
is different from what critics had I
don't understand why that's such a
bizarre concept for some people to
accept and I say that as someone who
does disagree with critics I have a lot
of problems with Star Wars last Jedi
it's got a 90 something on Rotten
Tomatoes doesn't mean I think that
there's a conspiracy to ensure a nod
90 rating and actually let's talk about
Rotten Tomatoes real quick just to get
it off the table so anyone who's
thinking that Rotten Tomatoes is the
source of the problem probably doesn't
really know how the aggregate site works
which is that they are not generating
the reviews they are pregnant braiding
together
the reviews that are out there being
done by various outlets and professional
critics and assigning a a value for a
percentage of how many said it was good
versus how many said it was bad they are
not creating the data they are simply
compiling it now theoretically you can
make an argument that that data can
still be manipulated in the same way
that any census takers survey taker
person putting together statistics can
manipulate data depending on how you ask
the questions how you just compile it
but Rotten Tomatoes is pretty
transparent about their process and more
to the point it's not like they're going
to people asking them these weirdly
worded or loaded questions with their
thoughts on movies they're looking at
and compiling the published publicly
available reviews of critics so in the
case of Rotten Tomatoes there the
messenger they aren't creating the
message they are just making it easy to
see in one place what the general
consensus is if there is one and more to
the point if Rotten Tomatoes was in on
this conspiracy
it wouldn't be weighted in favor of
Disney which is usually where the the
accusations go that Disney is buying off
critics because Disney is on a pretty
solid streak lately as far as critical
appraisal goes but if Rotten Tomatoes
was the source the problem trust me
they'd be favoring Warner Brothers
because Warner Brothers has a partial
stake in Fandango which is the parent
company of Rotten Tomatoes that was why
it was so iffy that Rotten Tomatoes
withheld putting up the percentage for
Justice League until the day it
premiered but again they weren't
changing the message they did delay how
long they would until they put it out
there but let's you're clear Rotten
Tomatoes off the table so as I said
Disney tends to be the big target of
these conspiracy theories and I don't
mean to use that as a belittling term
but I'm that that's what they are people
are believing that there is a
Spira see of bribery between Disney and
critics so let's just think about this
for a second
there are at this point hundreds of
professional critics watching and
reviewing movies release major movies
released by a company like Disney so if
they are bribing critics that means that
they are going to if not every let's say
80 percent or Egor you know what let's
go a little let's go 75 percent
they're going to say 75 percent of
critics and bribing them in some form to
ensure a positive review on their movies
to boost that and/or paying them to give
negative reviews to the competition the
very idea that you would come to that
conclusion that's a completely
results-based conclusion you looked at
something and came up with well it must
be this and then you tried to work
backwards to try and justify that
because there's no evidence the only
quote/unquote evidence is how highly
rated Disney movies are and how low
rated some other films from some other
Studios can be although not always so
that's basically the bulk of the
evidence and that's a big problem for me
because if people are gonna make claims
like this you need to realize there is
no way that if 75 percent of critics
were being bribed either to write
negative er to write positive that
nobody has talked and this is usually
the fundamental problem in most
conspiracy theories how many people it
would have to involve to actually
function as a conspiracy makes it almost
impossible that nobody would have blown
the whistle on this so especially in
terms of great now you need to realize
the kinds of critics that get aggregated
on to Rotten Tomatoes it's a pretty wide
variety from you know critics for the
New York Times and you know major
television networks to rinky-dink little
you know local newspapers and and and
medium sized websites
it really runs the gamut so you're
telling me that Disney is approaching
all these people from all these
different backgrounds from your well pet
well-paid critics whose names are
recognizable among moviegoers too little
nobody's heard of them whoever in podunk
somewhere and but and offering all of
them something that they are willing to
accept like nobody has said no nobody
has turned them down because think about
that there there should be somebody who
would have gone no I don't want to do
that or no I don't need the money or no
my integrity as a reviewers more
important to me to that and then why
would they not say hey by the way I was
offered a bribe because if other people
are taking this they would want to blow
the whistle on it and again I'm not I
could buy the argument that you offer
people money the majority of them will
take it but all that would take would be
one critic just one to go no and then
immediately post on a blog with email or
telephone or text correspondence proving
what it was that happened and it hasn't
and that's another thing I'm not sure
what people think is in it for either
side because if Disney is offering a
bribe that is sufficient enough that
nobody has said no which you have to
assume would be the case because like I
said if anybody has ever said no they'd
have every reason to blow the whistle on
this so if they're offering such a
significant bribe that no one has ever
said no then this is costing them so
damn much that whatever boost they think
they're getting from the box office
based on positive reviews it's got to be
a wash at best and that's ignoring the
fact that outside sources aside from
Rotten Tomatoes have determined that
that's statistically speaking that is
not even an inherently positive impact
on the box office or even inherently
negative one on the competition Studios
like to blame Rotten Tomatoes
Blayne critics right now but the data
doesn't bear that out and then there's a
question like well what would actually
be in it for the critics a temporary
influx of income but if it ever gets
uncovered which as I'm saying if it's as
far-reaching as it would kind of have to
be to ever work it would be almost
guaranteed to be uncovered at some point
their entire career gets flushed down
the toilet because they lose every scrap
of integrity they ever had again I'm not
saying that there's nobody who would go
for that deal but I can't imagine that
every critic would be going yes I will
cash in my integrity knowing that if
it's ever uncovered I will never get to
work in this field again and let's be
honest let's address some other things
have there ever been situations where
critics or other sort of influencers of
people's buying habits have been bribed
or coerced well yeah I mean it happens
in various degrees in various industries
in various ways but straight bribery
hasn't really happened for a very long
time like honestly the closest that
things come at this point is probably in
the video game industry when video game
publishers have like review retreats
where they bring critics in you knowing
make sure they're put up at a nice hotel
and give them plenty of time hands-on
time with the game because it makes them
you know they're not literally dictating
you must review with an X number for our
game but they are creating a climate and
a positive experience around them as a
company and whatever game it is that
they're promoting that will hopefully in
the critics mind link a general positive
feeling to the game it is a bit of a
psychological manipulation in that sense
so that sort of stuff does go on but
like I said video games do it movies not
so much because you don't really get
yeah I mean there are press screenings
but they're not retreats they're just
you go to the same theater you'll be
going to if you were paying to get in
they're not overly lavished they're not
going to the degree that some industries
have to just ensure that the critter
turn a real good mood in even if they
did like that's gonna be a minor thing
at best because no matter how good of a
mood you're in you see something crappy
you're still gonna call it crap now to
be fair there have there was a critic
scandal in this century in the 21st
century it was way back in the early
2000s and it didn't involve Disney it
involves Sony and what that was
in case you're younger than me which
having looked at my analyse for my
channel chances are you are then you
probably don't remember this but Sony
created a fake critic for a fake
newspaper and generated fake quotes from
reviews that never existed and stuck
them on posters of for Rob Schneider's
movie the animal and for the Heath
Ledger movie A Knight's Tale that was
all they did with it though because they
got caught real quick which again kind
of emphasizes my point the last time
that anything that could be called any
kind of a direct critical manipulation
attempt to fool or manipulate the system
was done it got busted like that after
two instances and again two to bribe
enough critics to actually seriously
impact something like a Rotten Tomatoes
score you'd have to be doing it with
hundreds of them last time this crab got
pulled it got caught after two again
there is no way it doesn't hold up and
it doesn't make sense it's not a
conclusion that you can come to based
off the scientific method of looking at
the evidence and what is the evidence
point to because the only way you land
here is by starting from the conclusion
of there must be reason that these
critics don't agree with me and look
it's annoying to feel very strongly
about a movie and realize that most
people don't feel that way and people
who are paid to look at this stuff don't
agree with you what and that's
regardless of whether you love something
that they all say is crap or whether you
hate something that they all say is
great
is frustrating trust me I get it
I mentioned the last Jedi it's having to
be with other movies I don't get why
everyone is head over heels for No
Country for Old Men
I don't think it's bad but I don't get
it I also really love GI Joe Rise of
Cobra in our world where we can embrace
dumb fun
like The Fast & Furious franchise it
annoys me that we couldn't embrace this
thing but that said I don't think
there's any conspiracy behind either of
those differences of opinion and again I
really do understand the frustration
especially if something that you don't
like continues to see a level of
excessive success that you don't
understand so if you don't like the
Marvel movies but you're watching them
get praise and praise and praise and
praise that can start to weigh on you if
you can start to feel like God it's like
the world's telling me I'm wrong and
nobody wants to think that about
themselves and to flip it around you
really like the DC movies up to this
point and everything that's coming out
is saying they're crap the crap the crap
they're crap it almost starts to feel
like a personal attack after a while you
feel like you want to fight back but it
doesn't mean that there's anything there
there's no there's no substance there's
no meat on this argument there's only a
conclusion there are bribing critics
where's your evidence they have a
different opinion for me anything else
other than that No so guys look if you
want to argue that critics are wrong
please by all means argue that critics
are wrong if you want to argue the
merits of a maligned movie please do
that if you want to point out the flaws
of a praised movie go for it but can we
stop at the very least in my own comment
section can we just stop with this
critics or bribe stuff and also you know
what I'll tell you what I will make a
pledge to you right now if this channel
ever grows to the point where I ever get
invited to a press screening of any film
if anybody from any studio approaches me
and offers me money for in exchange for
me giving a specific opinion I will tell
you all right now and I will immediately
go you guys are right there's conspiracy
I know it here's why that is my pledge
to you I don't think that's
we're gonna have to pay out though cuz
again I can't imagine that there's never
been anybody who doesn't feel the same
way I do which is that film and critical
analysis is more important than one
paycheck I can't be the only one there's
got to be somebody so if we could please
give that one a rest but with a great
trepidation I will now say what do you
think about all this whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to do all the things like
subscribe I'm on Twitter I have two
podcast I got an email all that stuff
for this link down below and until next
time
this council is adjourned
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]